all right people
i'm gonna i'm gonna have to yell here
i'll wait till we get about 100 of you
guys in then i'll start telling you
what's going on here
i am in beverly hills beverly freaking
hills
and i cannot believe what is going on
all right we got over 200 already
i i swung by the trump rally here
it is it is absolutely freaking bananas
look at this this is beverly hills
like we're in crazy california l.a
rodeo drive right over there look at
these american flags
there's happy people everywhere it's
like the twi everything
they tell you whatever they're telling
you about a trump rally it's it's the
reverse
whatever makes me decide i've never seen
so many happy
look at these look at this look at these
trucks
look at this
latinos for trump blacks for trump gays
for trump
i saw one-legged guy for trump this chip
for trump
this is just something else this guy
this guy this is this guy for trump you
live
bro
look i'm going to take a picture with
this lady we're live wait you got a
camera
um he's going to take the picture all
right here we go here we go smile there
you go
all right all right we're on video and
we're smiling
uh-oh take
the space man over here good to see you
space man
look at this all right i mean this is
this is
this is bananas it's truly bananas how's
it going man good to see you
look at the listen to the the trucks and
the cars driving by
that are honking is insanity
okay uh maybe maybe more a little bit
later
uh but it is just wild if you're out
here come say hi to me i've been saying
hi to a lot of people
it's fun and uh it's not what they'd
have you think people
just just craziness there you go one
more time
i'm seriously confused by the space man
let me let me see what i can find out
all right i'll be back
how do you shut this thing oh there we
go